welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in thick boy fight news is teaming up
with our good friend the shmo on our
brand new segment the shmo will know
today the shmo went down to sunny san
diego to cover the weigh-ins for ufc
fight night vera vs cruz for those who
don't know there has been some heat
between shido vera and dominic cruz and
the shmo has all the answers why howdy
thick boy enthusiasts this is the shmo
and this is the debut of the shmo will
know we're right outside the fighter
hotel here at ufc san diego just
finished up the weigh-ins in the main
event you got marlin chinoverra weighing
in at 135 and a half pounds and you have
the dominator dominic cruz weighing in
at 135 pounds a lot of people ask why is
there so much beef between the two the
shmo wouldn't say there's beef but we'd
say there's high tension high stakes you
got the dominator the inaugural ufc
bantamweight champion the three-time
champion looking to make another run at
title contention he got marlon chidovera
the up and comer looking to get his
first taste of ufc gold this is like a
title eliminator fight the stakes are
extremely high why because next week in
salt lake city ufc pay-per-view you've
got marav de volos feely against jose
aldo and then in abu dhabi a few months
from now you got pewter on taking on
sugar shawn o'malley and
the winner of both those fights could be
getting a title shot or if the winner of
this fight here in san diego wins in
grand fashion you can make a case they
are getting a title shot next bullshitto
and dominic cruz they spent a lot of
time in the ufc apex together doing
broadcast work not necessarily together
but they see each other across from the
octagon cheeto there doing the spanish
broadcast you got the domestic
pay-per-views and the fight nights here
in the united states being done by
dominic cruz in english english speaking
of course and then they both trained
right here in beautiful southern
california dominic cruz hometown affair
he trains here in san diego and then he
got cheeto vera and orange county the
tensions are high and they both know
what's at stake
and that's why you see what you see
the shmo
out
for those looking to make some money on
the main event draftkings has cheeto
vera as the minus 240 favorite and
dominic cruz as a plus 200 underdog the
draftking sportsbook seems confident the
bout will go the full five rounds with
the odds at -190 for the fight to go the
distance the light heavyweight division
seems to be moving forward with a title
rematch between yiri prohaska and glover
to shera prohaska shared a tweet that he
would like to fight december 10th at ufc
282 in las vegas to which teshera
responded let's go the rest of the
division does not seem to agree with the
move former champ jan wakovic has been
heavily campaigning on social media to
take on prohospha even going as far as
accusing the check for not following
through on his promise to fight him this
was enough for pro hoska to respond to
blakovich in a tweet i never promise you
or fight yanwakovic i just said you are
the challenge what i want to cut second
thing is i'm still waiting for answer
from glover to shara if you're not
interested let me know i want to fight
till the end of this year no matter who
yon then responded telling yuri that not
fighting him is a big missed opportunity
yiri this is not about promises made
this is a chance for the biggest
european fight in the history of this
sport this is it we're both men of
action we both have something to prove
the world now the opportunity arises and
we can create greatness the news of the
rematch also drew the attention of light
heavyweight contender jamal hill who
spoke with sports kedia to express his
concerns that the division might be
getting held up it's what we expected
but damn december a whole year of
fighting the same [ __ ] person yeah i
want it don't get me wrong i'm cool with
glover getting the rematch i wanted
glover to get the rematch but i thought
they would have at least got it out of
the way by like fall or some [ __ ] like
december 10th that's what it's like four
months and when they fight they fought
in may right what about the rest of the
division i want the title shot magamed
has the first crack at yawn the winner
of that has the first crack at whoever
wins that fight prohaska or tashera and
so i'll have to win another fight and
then you know what i'm saying and then
when is that going to be the end of next
year yeah that's irritating
looking ahead to ufc 278 paulo costa
appears to be ready for his middleweight
bout against luke rockhold in his last
fight against marvin vittori costa
didn't come close to making his 185
pound weight cut and the bout instead
took place at 205 in a recent tweet casa
shared that no such problems will occur
this time this time i have no injuries i
could surprise even by me beat my best
weight until here more muscles less fat
it's just my prime time as i said
unfortunately for all middleweight guys
god gave his grace and the knowledge to
make something unbelievable that wraps
up another week of thick boy fight news
before we go head into the weekend with
a laugh and enjoy this week's friday
funnies
[Music]
detour is wearing shoes so he will not
be able to strike
[Applause]
fish right afterwards and look how she's
running forward
and amanda just stops oh crap goodness
oh boy
the worst compliment of it
he said that he believes that one of the
kicks
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys
sean here recording the weather there's
95 percent chance
sean
[Music]
oh
oh
goodness the creativity
oh no
okay gosh it might be one of the best in
the game he's hurt he's not his problem
yes
yes
it's like two rounds to a melee thomas
is stalling there man
why do you keep turning away from him oh
my gosh oh holy cow he was out
looking for more original mma content
check out the rest of thick boy youtube
exclusive interviews opinion and fight
analysis is available weekly on the shop
show food truck diaries and fight night
flashbacks subscribe so you don't miss
any of the action
[Music]